the United Nations has suspended its
anti-torture mission to Australia after
its inspectors were refused entry at
several jails now the inspectors needed
to visit detention facilities to Monitor
and prevent brutality against detainees
they also collected or wanted to collect
relevant information
and documentation for their assessments
four years human rights groups had
voiced their concern about suspected
abuses in Australian prisons Youth
detention centers and immigration
facilities now the abuses they say were
targeting Aboriginal communities in
particular the un's anti-torture
missions have been suspended or
postponed in three other countries
Azerbaijan Ukraine and Rwanda
lorana Bartels the professor of
criminology at Australia National
University and she joins me now from
Canberra good to have you with us on the
program uh how surprised are you by the
move uh of the Australian authorities
extraordinary
move Australia ratified bobcat 27
sought an extension to the spt
delegation coming in undertaking those
inspections initially to get the
relevant
processes in place and then due to
covert but it was hardly a surprise that
the inspection would be taking place so
all the relevant organizations are well
and truly on notice that this would be
coming and have that suspended as really
quite remarkable I mean where are the
sticking points here because you're a
federally Run Country but even the
federal government has to negotiate
individually with states to actually get
things done and with State institutions
they don't seem to be on the same page
when it comes to this International body
yes that's correct so obviously
Australia as as a country has ratified
opcat but in Australia the prisons are
run by the Six States and the two
militaries
um now all of those were as I say I
noticed that this would be happening and
it's actually only two of the states New
South Wales and Queensland and in
Queensland to only relation in fact to
the mental health facilities not for
prisons only two states have
um said that they said that they
wouldn't provide access the other states
and territories didn't in fact provide
access to their facilities and in fact
the Australian attorney Commonwealth
Attorney General has now issued um an
exhortation to those two states New
South Wales and Queensland to allow that
access so that the inspectors can return
and complete their inspections as was of
course envisage so finally I mean how
quickly does that really have to happen
to limit the damage to Australia's
reputation of this particular instance
because you don't I'm sure want to be
lumbered in the same group as Azerbaijan
Rwanda or even Ukraine
look I think significant damage has
already been done and I think
um a lot of us who work in this space
are around really of the view of if we
had nothing to hide then there really
would be no concern uh and in fact in
the in the jurisdiction where I live in
the Australian Capital territory the
corrections commissioner said you know
the inspectors are welcome in compliance
with the requirements and if they have
any recommendations you know in
principle we would be happy to take them
on board
um that's the sort of approach that I
think jurisdictions should be willing to
take
um to ensure that they are practicing in
compliance with their human rights
obligations but the reality is that we
have been
um faced with extraordinary
um I think
um scandals I think is a fair word to
describe our prisons and youth detention
centers across Australia as you said in
your introduction especially when it
comes to the treatment of average on
Torres Strait Islander people then has
been a royal commission there is
currently a class action in relation to
Youth detention in two states Western
Australia and Tasmania there is
currently an inquiry in one of those
States in Tasmania
um there are
um there's really no justification for
Australia to show its obligations and to
shy away from scrutiny when it's pretty
clear that there are human rights abuse
taking place we shall see how quickly
this is all rectified for the moment
lorana Bartels thanks so much for
joining us from Canberra
thank you